I can't believe that it's already been
one month since the iPhone 11 and 11 Pro
have been released overall I am happier
than I expected to be with these new
phones but that doesn't mean that the
iPhone 11 Pro isn't without fault let's
get a huge obvious one out of the way
and that is 3d touch they say you don't
know what you've got until it's gone and
that is absolutely the case here I first
noticed the differences last year since
I switched to the iPhone 10 our when
working on that review and I have to say
the haptic touch is a much worse
experience I know I know
battery life and all of that but
personally I would take a slight hit in
battery life and still have this
additional layer on the display that
allows me to open things faster and more
precisely because the battery life is
already just so good with this phone my
next complaint is the matte back I love
the look and that it isn't a fingerprint
magnet but when using the phone
one-handed I've literally had it slip
out of my hands multiple times compared
to the 10s assignee glass back that
offered a lot more grip I know I'm in
the minority of users who use their
iPhone without a case but I'll still be
keeping it that way because I love the
way this thing just looks and feels
being nice and fairly slim without a
case on top of it but I definitely am
considering picking up a grippier skin I
won't be talking too much more about
hardware or design but of course I do
wish Apple finally made the move to USB
type-c with this pro moniker that they
added along with a faster refresh rate
and also that 64 gigs of base-level
storage for a thousand bucks is pretty
ridiculous what's not as obvious is the
software I will be talking about RAM
management in just a bit but let's start
out with a few things the Apple has
pretty much fixed and other things that
hopefully they will soon the first one
is something that we've been complaining
about for years not being able to
quickly change your video recording in
the current beta we can now press on the
resolution or the frame rate to swap
through them personally I would rather
have the full menu pop-up to access all
of the settings but this is definitely a
huge improvement the only other thing
that can complain about camera wise is
night mode with the ultra wide apple
most likely didn't add this since the
quality wouldn't match up with the other
two lenses because there's no optical
stabilization with the ultra wide and
the sensor is also smaller but I know
that the quality
would still be much better for nighttime
photos than having to use The Awl tried
without night mode the no 10 plus also
has an ultra-wide lens without
stabilization but they still let you use
night mode and those photos come out
fairly decent usable compared to having
pretty much dark black photos with ultra
wide if you're shooting at night with
iphone 11 Pro maybe that's just another
thing they're saving for next year like
USB type-c
and maybe another feature that I really
want which is an always-on display I've
used Samsung Galaxy phones a fair bit
and they're always on displays are quite
useful I understood why the iPhone 8
didn't have it because of its LCD
display and maybe the battery life being
the reason that the olan iPhone 10 and
10s didn't offer it but now that the
iPhone 11 Pro has super good battery
life why not offer it the iPhone 11 Pro
has a super good display the overall
quality is similar to the note 10 plus
but apple allows you to manually turn it
up much brighter and if you have a lot
of white on the screen it doesn't dim
like other phones unfortunately after a
month the YouTube still doesn't support
HDR playback I'm not sure if this is
just YouTube's fault but we've had for
YouTube app updates since Typhon 11 was
released and that feature is still not
there whereas last year in the iPhone
10s had support in less than a week
because of this some HDR videos look
worse on the 11pro
than they do on the iPhone 10s so
hopefully this will get a fix soon and
it's not some other issue that is
holding it back another thing that
really jumped out of me is Apple's use
of the ultra wide lens during FaceTime
when face timing I often tried to show
something to my kids or to my wife so
I'll switch over to the rear lens and
then that way can show them something
say at the store but now with the ultra
wide lens it gives you a really super
wide distorted image and then when you
bring it up closer just doesn't look
good and then not only that if you have
slow internet connections like over LTE
all the pixelation and that distortion
really makes the image kind of unusable
to show something off where's what the
iPhone 10s it was much better this
should be a fairly easy software fix
just giving us a couple buttons to be
able to swap between different lenses so
hopefully Apple will add that in now
let's talk about RAM management just
like the iPhone 10's the 11s have four
gigabytes of RAM
which is two to three times less than
many of its competitors people say the
i/os is much better optimized which is
true but after using some higher and
androids and now going to the 11pro I
routinely have background apps that
close and I have to reload the app
losing where I was that it even seems
worse than my iPhone 10s which just
doesn't make sense my only guess is that
iOS 13 keeps less apps open maybe it's
just save battery life or some other
reason but it's something that I deal
with almost daily now I'm definitely a
much heavier phone user than the average
person but this is a non-issue with the
note 10 plus and the 1 + 7 + 70 Pro
those will even preload your most used
apps ahead of time in the background and
I think for a base price of $1,000 the
iPhone 11 pro should at least have come
with 6 gigs of RAM let me know if there
are any other issues that I didn't bring
up that you're facing down in the
comment section below
click above to subscribe and then down
below to enable those notifications if
you guys want to see a few more great
videos like this one there's a few
options right over there this is the max
max tech and I will see you guys in the
next video
[Music]